à à
anh
alo cho các bạn
ừ ừ
Xin
chào Bạn nghe rõ không ạ Alo ạ
Hôm nay nhìn cái tiêu đề tổn thế sợ thì
để hôm nay sẽ rất là dài
à à
Ừ hi vọng hôm nay trực ra hôm trước có
bạn hỏi là kiểu cái này hợp để cho đồ ăn
hai à Rồi cái học là để
trong buổi hôm đấy Mình có nói rồi đó là
kiểu đòn mua thì chúng ta các bạn không
cần cái này và đồ ăn hay được các bạn
cũng không thử cái chẳng cần cái này vì
gj nó không phải là cái gì đó Bây giờ
phổ biến nữa Ngân hàng ra là không phải
cứ áp dụng vào được
nhưng mà
Học để cho biết thôi học để biết được ra
kiếp có thể làm những gì Và có những thứ
viện thể
giúp việc cố Taylor Swift nhanh hơn ở
tiện hơn giả sử như là hôm nay học về
vaj chẳng hạn thì rõ ràng mà mình đừng
dùng ra xíu về hết rồi thì như hôm nay
có hẳn thư viện để làm nó màu mè hơn và
nhanh hơn vân vân
Ừ thì đấy Đấy do mình sẽ dạy các bạn với
cái này bởi vì toàn bộ những cái cơ bản
về pp là gần như là thật ra vẫn còn
thiếu nhiều cái nhưng mà một cái trang
web cơ bản thì ta chỉ cần tương đối thì
thôi không cần không cần học thêm học
thêm nữa thì nó bắt đầu nghỉ xanh trong
web nâng cao rồi nên là thực ra toàn bộ
những cái kiến thức mà các bạn
Á đù điện đủ đồ bếp để tên VP rồi thì đủ
làm cái đồn một rồi Còn bây giờ còn thời
gian chẳng lẽ lại bảo các bạn bảo vệ đồ
ăn luôn Thế nên là bây giờ mình đang dạy
thêm cái cái dạy thêm này kiểu ai ai
thấy xem học được và kiểu đi tham khảo
thôi Như mình đã nói để tham khảo chứ
không có màn hình chất là kiểu bắt các
bạn phải làm này trong đó án phải có
trong đồ ăn luôn
khi mà các bạn hoàn toàn mà
à
à á Chắc truyền đi rồi cho nó báo lỗi về
á Hôm nay mình sẽ làm vụ này đây
à Hôm nay mình sẽ làm nên quan kiểm tra
dữ liệu trả về đúng hay sai cũng thật
cái thứ trước khi cho cho nó kiểu xử lý
tiếp không ạ Hôm trước thì mình cứ để
cho mặc định là đúng
xã
hội mà mình học làm đồ ăn một thì mình
cũng Các bạn nhớ cái trang web mình đừng
cho bạn xem đoán một rồi người ta mình
có chè thì một tí xíu giở đấy và đấy à
mình à tự mò thôi mình còn chưa nắm rõ
được Syria là cái gì Vân
thợ lò khá nhiều thế Đấy là thầy cũng
tiểu thì chỉ nói tên tên công nghệ rồi
để cho sinh viên tự more để tránh sinh
viên kiểu ham hố đi tìm hiểu về công
nghệ nhiều quá mà không chú trọng vào
chức năng của đoán
thế
nhưng nhưng mà đó là nhược điểm khi mà
kiểu để mò tự mò mới nhiều bạn tự mò nó
cứ bị đi xa quái không đi đâu cả nhà
mình mới mình mới nghĩa thôi dậy luôn
Ừ nhưng mà dậy như này thì sẽ có nhược
điểm là sẽ chất sáng có vài ông kiểu làm
chưa xong hết tính năng nữa ham hồ thêm
một đống công nghệ về
Em ở chỗ nào Cái này các bạn phải phải
vẫn phải biết à lượng sức mình này và
sắp xếp cho phù hợp là sửa kiểu tất cả
tính năng cơ bản phải cho Suốt các thử
thử đã Đừng ôm gj rồi A giác về
cái này rõ ràng là các bạn thấy ra hôm
trước là mình
tính năng của với mình xong hết rồi
chẳng hạn trang web mình xong hết tính
năng rồi mình mới bắt đầu kia
khi nhúng a sắc về để cho nó kiểu không
phải nó trang nghĩa làm triển tính năng
pvp vẫn được xử lý xong hết rồi đúng
không ạ Cứ chứ không không nói chuyện
kiểu đang vừa cốt vừa kết hợp tiêu đi về
Isaac
à à
à Hôm nay thì các bạn xem đấy Hôm nay
mình sẽ
đầu tiên là sẽ dùng mua đồ mô đây chắc
là có can thiệp của boss chap 1 tí rồi
mua đồ của Wechat sau đó thì kết hợp với
kiểu Đăng nhập đăng ký ngồi Violet thằng
cả bằng Serie A Jack các thứ
à à
từ trước đấy thì cho các bạn xem cái
video này đã nhé
ạ Bây giờ vẫn đang thời gian tâm sự mà
nó ngoại chưa tìm ra học bộ đề thi Tự
tập bớt cái này
anh nhìn cốt đoạn này tôi Chồng sợ vợ à
à à
Ừ
[âm nhạc]
hihi
resort
Hihi
resort Do you love and to All For One is
well and one in parasyte Anime Princess
như thế nào free Token implemented for
the People all died inbox jakeman
depends on the last Minutes people
centre cancel quái big heart was getting
all three rivers are you anh biết nó cho
tao con x in Everything from free Games
to People speak inquiry and use Walls
are you What you people that like video
Face turned out for the way that all
that I can tell you care about What
tomorrow Eva Nice stuff And rather that
about you and deal with money for free
with me
what's your name is tomorrow I
thì các bạn thấy đúc kết từ cái video
vừa rồi
ở tại Hải ý của anh đấy à anh đấy à
a z đầu miễn phí bởi vì a thấy à con
người giờ là không trân trọng những cái
gì ở miễn phí
mình mới xem cái video là từ vừa nãy
thôi mà mình thấy khá phù hợp với cửa
thực ra là
cái bài toán về tâm lý nó vẫn là tâm lý
thôi
anh nói thế Không phải à thôi ok bắt đầu
từ bây giờ tôi sẽ thu phí học các bạn
thì các bạn Trân trọng việc học của tôi
hơn không phải như thế mà là
mình đang muốn nói các bạn là để mời các
bạn
khi vượt qua được cái tâm bày tỏ tâm lý
học
vừa rồi để mà trân trọng những cái mà
kiểu thực sự nên đáng trân trọng ở lại
Ừ cái này không phải gửi mỗi khóa của
mình mà khóa của mình thì K là mình à
anh
tím mình sẽ nói luôn rồi khó mình như
thế nào Cảm nhận mình về khóa của mình
nếu mà đấy Thì đại khái cái bài toán tâm
lý học với mình thường mình thường hay
thường anh nghĩ nó vào mình à nghĩa là
nếu mà con người ở đó một vượt qua được
những cái tâm lý học theo kiểu là tâm lý
đám đông này tâm lý đảo ngược này để có
rất nhiều cái mà Mấy ông vượt qua được
một cái đấy nếu không sẽ gần như là
trưởng thành này và suy nghĩ bằng một
cái đầu lạnh và trở thành con người nói
chung là làm chủ được
Ê mấy ông của bé ông mà đọc về tâm lý
học người không dễ thấy có rất nhiều cái
nhà tâm lý học và theo kiểu là nó chi
phối con người khác
em thậm chí ở đôi khi là tôi áp dụng tâm
lý học với mấy ông em mày không biết rồi
thì nếu mấy ông mà nhận ra được điều đấy
cho nó giống kiểu thôi miên kể về ông
làm kẹo thức tỉnh khỏi cái đấy thế chẳng
sẽ trở thành con người thì gì đó ngoại
gọi là
à à
Mỹ Tâm bất dịch giữa dòng dòng đời à
dòng đời số đề quyền sử rồi
tắt Tâm bất biến giữa dòng đời vạn biến
cái cảnh như thế ế
à
à tiếp theo là về à
Em thích heo là về khóa học của mình cảm
nhận của mình thì
nhà mình gần đây thì da mình có
em có gặp
phải bạn tự nhiên là mình gặp vài bạn à
Ở
Ừ tự nhiên bạn để ở ngoài đời sau đó thì
mình
khi mình về mình xem cho anh trang cá
nhân thì hóa ra bạn thấy thành là hot
Tik Tok cơ này rồi hot youtuber này mình
cảm thấy à Gọi bây giờ mình mình à
ở
đời mình thấy mình nhỏ bé kinh khủng khi
mà Kìa
mình từng nghĩ mình to tát sau một vài
người
ex2 ở xung quanh tôi như thế cho anh khi
đưa thấy
nhiều tích nhiều Tik Tok cơ kinh khủng
nghỉ ở dưới Super kinh khủng người lượng
người theo dõi khùng
A và tự nhiên là họ đăng những cái chết
rồi tôi không nói việc Những cái ông mới
băng rất ngắn ý mà được nhiều người theo
dõi nhé Thì
anh đã tương tự như thế thì về cả những
thầy cô mà
được nhiều người theo dõi
khi tôi cảm thấy kiểu dạng mà tôi khá
nhỏ bé cho những người ấy
khi tôi cũng tự tin chứ nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ nữa à
Ừ để mà để mà được nhưng hỏi thì ra là
họ chưa cả họ làm
anh theo kiểu thứ nhất là họ đấy công
việc của họ rồi Họ biến đấy công việc
của họ rồi Nghĩa họ dành toàn bộ thời
gian nó nó chăm chút cho nó và à
Anh làm tài liệu soạn giáo án chỉnh sửa
video vân vân vân lên lên trong kế hoạch
của rất là chi tiết tỉ mỉ cho tất cả
từng từng người video từng nội dung của
họ còn mình thì
Ừ mình thì thực ra là mình vẫn đang dạy
các bạn đã theo
không hẳn là theo cảm hứng bởi vì mình
có kinh nghiệm rồi mình có kinh nghiệm
và kiểu
cho mình hình như mình chỉ có kinh
nghiệm về kết hợp với cả
sự ứng biến chứ không có chứ không có
kiểu dạng mà lên kế hoạch một cách chi
tiết cũng như là
mình không có đủ thời gian để mà chăm
chút cho tất cả video
cho các thứ tưởng là miếng thời gian
chỉnh sửa video hay là các thứ thứ
Ừ tí được ca chính cái thời chính cái à
những những cái mình bỏ ra không bằng họ
nên là thứ ra mình cũng không thể là
mong đợi như họ được đến hình nhá giống
như là cái á
anh Fanpage của tôi trả lại tôi đang
nghĩ việc à Tôi từng nói Tôi sẽ thỉnh
thoảng đang ảnh hay nhạc hay gì đó Những
cái sở thích của tôi chẳng ạ chia sẻ lên
mọi người
nhận ra hình như là mọi người Nếu là sử
mọi người thấy cậu mọi người thấy thì
chắc chỉ thích thôi chứ chắc là họ đã
kiểu chia sẻ nó bàn tán thì nó
Ừ nó khác với trâu Giả sử giáo xứ như là
bây giờ một sân công nghệ Chắc là anh
tôi đi Có dạo đi
Ừ
anh đây đã xây đủ đồ tiếng tăm và độ nói
chung ơi hình tượng đủ lâu rồi để mà khi
người ta một cái gì đó rất nhiều người
muốn chia sẻ nó có nhiều người sẽ bình
luận vào trong đấy ví dụ ở già ý rồi nhé
đó là
có một bài giả sử là một bài Tôi đang
nghĩ sẽ toàn người chỉ có ba mấy người
lại thích Thôi chẳng ạ ờ ờ còn một bài
người đang thì sẽ là đến
hướng để gấp 10 lần nên là ít và 300 là
ạ trạng 300 đấy sẽ do tâm mấy mấy người
bình luận sau đó một hoặc hai người hay
lời chia sẻ thôi
em thiệt thế Cũng là nhiều rồi ngoan ạ
Ừ
nhưng mà họ là họ đầu tư thực sự vào tất
cả những cái đấy thế nên là nội dung của
họ chất lượng người ta thích tương tác
những cái đấy còn bây giờ tôi mà đăng
những cái
lên mà không Không có đầu tư thì đơn
giản Cái này hay này mấy ông nghe đi em
ạ Mấy ông cha gì vào là thích mấy ông
nghe thôi
em Nếu người không biết còn không muốn
nghe Tiến thích thôi cho động viên
Ừ cái thì
Ừ thôi Tôi nghĩ là chắc là tôi khi mà có
thời gian tới sẽ vậy cho chuốt rất nhiều
cái fanpage đấy tôi Cha tôi sẽ phải theo
suốt đăng là theo dạng khác
à à
có tư duy của em kém em chỉ chịu khó thì
có theo học lập trình được không Cái này
mình từng nói với sinh viên mình rồi đó
là
ngành đạo thế thôi Ngày nào cũng
Nếu mà bạn thông minh thì cứ trả mà bạn
sẽ đi nhanh hơn nhưng mà nó hơi bị cũng
hơi bị ngược so với ngày này không mấy
ngày khác nào nhá những ngày ngày nó sẽ
bị lừa cái điểm có một sự thật đó Chính
như bạn cái về đi hay bạn nói nói em
chịu khó cái Chịu khó mấy là cái yếu tố
cần
chỉ cần ở trong cái ngành Công nghệ
thông tin này ít nhất như thế cái thông
minh không phải là yếu tố đủ không phải
là số cần nói chỉ yếu tố để khiến cho
chúng ta tiến nhanh hơn nhưng mà chính
vì cái tiến nhanh hơn đấy
sẽ
không tốt ở trong cái ngành công nghệ
tin này lắm Tại sao bởi vì nhé tôi từng
quen khá như ông giỏi Ừ ông ấy học Công
nghệ pin có nhé sau đó thì ông ấy học
một thời gian ông ấy thấy thực ra để mà
nhiều nhà ông giỏi đấy nhiều người còn
Hàn và chất nữa và thực sự thì theo
ngành Công nghệ thông tin này
anh không khiến các bạn giàu nhanh được
làm giàu nhanh nhỉ ra một à Thì cướp
ngân hàng nghĩa cước từ
người khác họ hay làm gì đó Phi Pháp 3
là nhân kinh doanh đấy thì thì dùng anh
được chứ làm công nghệ thông tin về cơ
bản thì vẫn à làm công ăn lương thì
không thể giàu nhanh được chứ Khi ông tự
mở Sharp cái gì đó vẫn kinh doanh nhân
thành ra là
những bạn thông minh theo ngành này Ừ họ
tính nhanh đấy nhưng họ sĩ nhanh trám và
không không có không thỏa mãn được nhu
cầu làm giàu bạn ấy lại thứ nhất thứ hai
là
ngành cũng không tin này dù tin nhanh
chắc nữa vẫn phải học hỏi rất nhiều
Anh khiến cho kiểu bạn đấy cũng dễ bị
lạc và đứng yên à Không ai có thể cốt mà
không ra bất được người thông minh hai
người Người thông minh thì sẽ ra bất
thông minh khi con người kém thì sẽ ra
bất kém bất kém ở bếp bớt thông minh nữa
là gì bớt mức thông minh lắm chỉ ở rất
khó để mà phát hiện ra cái bớt đấy Nó
kiểu phải giữa cao siêu thì mới nhận ra
được
tội từng nói với ông đó là khi mà em
đang sản xuất đấy mấy ông đừng có cốt
Bởi vì khi mà mày ông sản xuất nó cũng
sẽ cốt vẫn cố tình thôi nhưng mà sẽ ra
được những quả bất mà phải các bạn phải
đền cái ngưỡng thông minh Gấp đôi thì
các bạn mình có thể mới sửa một cái bớt
đấy Anh thành ra là các bạn tự làm khó
bản thân để nó gọn thông minh rồi các
bạn xảy ra gia đình những cái bớt mà
không ai sợ được khiến chính các bạn
không sửa được
nghe với là nó thế là là chính vì cái
nản đấy
thì người thông minh ta lại khó vượt qua
nếu và sự người đã không chịu khó họ
nghĩ là họ giỏi rồi Tại sao họ lại phải
chịu khó vất vả nhớ thế họ sẽ bỏ họ sẽ
chuyển ngay và họ sẽ không tốt nữa họ sẽ
nhảy dàng cái kiểu cũng công tin nhưng
mà sẽ lên làm leader lên làm gì đó khác
đi tiểu thường là nó nhảy sang bên Phân
tích phân tích Thay vì cô ấy thì sẽ ổn
hơn bởi vì không tạo ra bất gì thế ạ Đấy
con người lập trình viên mình ở chúng ta
nên kiểu chịu khó hiểu Chịu khó học hỏi
chứ có thay đổi khi mà khách hàng hay
sếp đòi thay đổi chịu khó thay đổi công
nghệ khi mà giờ sử ngôn ngữ là Giang bị
lỗi thời rồi xong rồi học hỏi thêm nhiều
cái vân vân
em học hỏi cả cốt người khác họ cảnh hò
cái sữa bắp Vân rất nhiều thứ để học hỏi
đến bây giờ đến bản thân tôi rồi
tôi ngoài việc để cốt chạy Tôi còn phải
học cách thì tôi như trở lại ạ Đấy hàng
ra là
Ừ cái yếu tố cần trong ngành này lại là
kiên nhẫn chịu khó chứ không phải là
thông minh
Ồ thông minh
Ừ tôi thấy nó sẽ biến thành nhược điểm
như tôi đã nói tôi không biết người tham
quan điểm này là như là đối với tôi nó
thế
ở cốt nhiều các bạn sẽ tự thấy mình
thông minh dần đây
anh không Không cần phải so với kia hả
Sao bạn thân thôi tôi toàn thế đó là cư
do bạn thân mình mình đã làm một bản sao
tốt hơn so với mình cách đây một năm thì
nửa năm hay là thậm chí vài tháng trước
chưa thế được
Ừ đúng ạ mức lương Các bạn đã được tăng
lên chưa Đừng nói Vân là như thế Mình đã
tiến bộ hơn rồi chồng ạ
em không ăn sò người khác người khác có
thể vừa mới đi làm lương người ta thể
đến nghìn đô con nhà người ta không ạ Ừ
thì mình cũng tự đi đấy nhưng mà mình
không vì thế mà thôi Mình không làm ngày
nữa mình sẽ chỉ làm ngày làm 1 phát
lương mình nghìn đô dùng nó làm đi bây
giờ đấy không ạ thì mình mình chọn chọn
một cái gì đó một mình cảm thấy à
Ừ thứ nhất là nó có tiềm năng thứ hai là
nhà mình có thể theo được
anh có thể theo được khác với việc có
thể kéo ngang có thể theo được người
khác đứng ạ Có thể theo được có thể học
được
sống rồi đừng nghĩ việc là có thể có
đừng lui rất nhiều hối hội tôi Tôi từng
nói à
Ê hồi trước ở lớp tôi ăn nhiều là tỷ lệ
đi làm cao và các bạn đấy lúc mới vào
thì bạn đấy là từ ở quê lên bạn đấy chưa
từng động của máy tính mà đã thế mà đã
nhảy sang học lập trình rồi Cái đấy thì
cái là nhiều người sẽ buồn cười kìa kiểu
còn chưa biết cách mở máy tính như nào
chứ chưa nhìn thấy cái bàn phím Ờ phải
gõ luôn có cả nhìn cực ngồi quỳ xuống
bàn phím mì gõ từng phím một đấy nhé bạn
đấy không có đường lui
a&d sẽ hiểu
mà tốn hết thời gian và tiền bạc cho
việc học này rồi bạn sẽ treo đứng cung
bạn sẽ không có suy nghĩ việc nào lại
chịu khó bạn có vấn đề gì bạn sẽ cố
Ừ nó khác mày nhiều người bây giờ có
điều kiện họ lại kiểng
Ừ cố tìm cái gì gì đó mà kiểu vừa nhàn
vừa vân vân gì đó rất nhiều cái thôi có
mông lung nữa nhiều lựa chọn thành ra là
không chú tâm làm à Một cái gì đều có
thể cả
vì thế quá sai
à Tôi nghĩ à tuổi trẻ đúng ở nên có trải
nghiệm nhiều
Ừ nhưng mà
Để mình chọn cái gì mình phải làm cái
đấy Có tâm với nó vợ tôi nói với tôi
từng đi làm bồi bàn ở các thứ thứ
Ừ tôi vẫn hoàn toàn hết đặt hết tâm
huyết vào nó
a cho đến khi đến cái ngưỡng mà mình
không hỏi thêm gì mình nghĩ là kỹ năng
của mình học hỏi chị đến được đến lần
này thôi Và mình thấy là thực ra nó
không phải phù hợp với mình thì mình bỏ
không sao cả
Vì vậy tôi chả còn gì hết
Ừ đợi tí con chó nó cắn đấy
ok không Mày tâm sự thế được rồi
ừ ừ
các bạn em tiến tiến nhanh học tùm lum
mấy cái công nghệ đúng không còn em thì
chăm học mấy cái cũ để cho kẹo để luyện
đúng không
ờ ờ
Ừ cái này thì lại là bài toán mà mình
từng nói về cái dân công nghệ nó có thể
hai hướng
anh giống như hướng mùa hướng hướng trên
sau thì rất là tốt nhưng cũng có thể Mùi
hướng ở hướng cậu ạ à hướng toàn diện
thế là cái gì không biết
Ừ cái hướng toàn diện thở ra là cũng
được nhưng mà nhưng mà đến và các bạn
chuyên sâu được thì sẽ trả lương các bạn
sẽ cao hơn còn nhưng mà hướng toàn diện
thì giống kiểu đa-zi-năng như Hiện tại
mình mình thì nhảy sạm phần này mình làm
nhảy sang cả bên urquell rồi mình làm
thì rất nhiều công ty cũng rất thích
người đấy và người ấy sẽ hiểu được sự
chặng cũng được coi trọng đấy
anh nói chung là tùy tình huống đấy các
bạn cảm thấy cái nào phù hợp thôi hơn
thôi cả hai cách đều được không sao cả
chuyên trên được càng tốt nhưng mà nhưng
mà đừng có kiểu chuyên về cái cũng chỉ
là không học được cái mới không học được
cái mới lại khác nhé Bấm gì ông cụ ông
chỉ học được một ngôn ngữ sản không nghe
học được ngôn ngữ khác nhưng khác Còn
đây là chúa khắp chán chê xong cái ngôn
ngữ mất tận kịp thời sửa ông Bất Tận 5
hình 6 năm để chuyên pp ạ Đấy sau đó thì
bây giờ công ty mà
bảo các bạn để sang Java ra Suite các
bạn Học lại từ đầu thì vẫn được không
sao cả Chẳng sao cả bởi vì các bạn đã có
nền tảng của ngôn ngữ lập trình các bạn
hiểu rõ Toàn bộ thế nào về lập trình rồi
thì bạn nhảy xa người khác mà vẫn vẫn dễ
rồi công nghệ mới ở đây nó không có gì
to tát ghê gớm mà nó sẽ chỉ có vài cái
thay đổi vài cái từ ngôn ngữ sẽ có thế
mạnh riêng với Vân
em có bạn chỉ cần
học cái khác biệt của nó thôi đấy
ừ ừ
Ừ
ok
tiếp theo câu hỏi
anh ở đây có hai câu hỏi ở
có một câu hỏi này à
ở đó là bạn hôm trước bạn ấy có hỏi cái
việc là các bạn nhớ về cái đặt đơn không
ạ đặt hàng ạ
em sợ nhiều bạn quên rồi à
ở đầu tiên thì các bạn Nếu có thể hóa
đơn thì mình sẽ có cái bảng
về thì mình mở bảng anh nhé
à à
ừ ừ
thì mình sẽ có 23 là bạn hóa đơn và linh
chi tiết và bảo hóa đơn của mình sẽ có
cột mã tự động tăng và bảo hóa đơn chi
tiết sẽ dựa theo lấy cái cột ID đấy cột
mã đấy Ở trong này về mà thêm mã sản
phẩm để mà để mà kiểu mình biết được là
đơn đấy đã đặt những gì đó ngoại thì hôm
trước là có bạn nói về cái vụ trường hợp
khí hữu mà mình nói bây giờ xử Giả sử
đây nhá đó là
ở đầu tiên thì khi mình Insert vào trong
bão đồ bảng hóa đơn đấy mà để mã tự động
tăng nữa ông ạ thì vì là mã tự động bang
Nhưng khi mình lấy mắc mắt ID
em lấy cái mã lớn nhất từ cái bảo hóa
đơn thì có trường hợp có thể xảy ra đây
đó lại Nếu giả sử mà cùng ấn thanh toán
cùng một lúc thì thì cái mã hoặc mã lớn
nhất đấy thì nó sẽ là do sử là
là hang Hai người cùng ấn thanh toán
cùng một lúc thì cái mã hóa đơn lớn nhất
nó sẽ ra hai hạng của hai người nó sẽ
giống hệt nhau và nó sẽ đặt vào trong
hóa đơn chi tiết vào một đơn thôi nghĩa
Dồn hết toàn bộ sản phẩm bằng một đơn
chứ còn đơn còn lại thì sẽ không có sản
phẩm nào ra thế sau đó ông ạ
nên nó hôm trước mình đã bảo là mình có
thể our customer ID nghĩa là làm gì là
mình mình sẽ hiểu theo khách hàng hiện
đại có thể kéo khách hàng bởi vì thường
mà khách hàng sẽ không nói chuyện là sẽ
hiếm sẽ hiếm việc đăng nhập vào để cùng
Đạt đơn cùng một lúc Ừ nhưng mà đấy Gọi
lại khiến mình thực ra vẫn có thể xảy ra
vụ này vẫn thấy xảy ra vụ này đó là ăn
chỉ là
em ăn gia sư tử kéo hứng lên đi Biết đâu
đấy nó mở 2 Tab mà nó thanh toán hai cái
đơn đấy nó ngoại thì điều đấy vẫn thể
rửa ra thế là mấy giờ nhăn việc là đơn
sản phẩm của đơn này nhảy vợ đơn kia thì
chỉ có thể là đừng nói cho mã tự động
tăng nữa
cô đơn giản đấy thôi mình sẽ tự tự đầu
tiên là mình sẽ lấy mã lợn nhất từ trong
bào hóa đơn theo khách hàng này chẳng
hạn hay là không không còn thiếu khách
hàng ở đó
ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ làm gì mình sẽ Mình
nãy tự tự tăng cái mã lớn nhất để tăng
lên một rồi Mình in rất là trong hóa đơn
và Insert vào trong cả họ hóa đơn chi
tiết thì bởi vì mã đấy nó cho cả hai bà
cùng một lúc mới này ra đơn sản phẩm của
đơn đấy nó chắc chắn sẽ thuộc đơn đấy
rồi nó sẽ có những điểm là khi mà giả sử
mà khi Insert là sẽ bị lỗi
anh Bởi vì giống như tôi vừa nói là bởi
mã không tự động tăng lên có thể việc mã
có thể trùng đúng không ạ Nhưng mà nếu
mà bị chồng như thế thì ông chỉ việc và
kiểm tra nếu mà khi mày rớt bị máy queo
Euro tất cả bị lỗi thì ông Tăng ông chạy
vòng lặp ông chạy vòng lặp đấy để tăng
nó lên 1 rồi in rớt lại xem có được
không để pin rất lạ vẫn không được thì
lại tăng lên một tiếp tôi sẽ như thế cho
đến khi in sẽ được thì thôi thường là
thực ra là không nói chuyện mà chạy vòng
lặp nó chạy chục lần đâu vì mắc mắt ID
theo khách hàng mà khách hàng làm sao
đọc được chục đơn cùng một lúc mà bị
trùng liên tục được không ạ Cái gần như
là mã của ông sẽ không sẽ hiểu
em luôn là duy nhất và phù hợp với
Insert được vào cả hai bà không nói
chuyện là sản phẩm của đơn lại nhảy vào
của đơn kia
cho tôi Tôi không nói tôi tôi nói trai
thế tôi không cốt ở đây vì thực ra là
cái bài toán đây nó hi hữu
à à
Ừ mình gì à Không biết cái hàm Insert ID
kia nhưng hình như là cái đấy là Insert
rồi lấy đi thì phải nhớ Thế
mình mình chưa thử mình chưa thử vụ đấy
mình chưa được rồi đâu nha Nhưng mà nếu
mà giờ sự ý sẽ lấy được cái điên nữa
thủng ngoại thì cái hàng họ
cũng không đúng lắm không đúng lắm vì
vậy đúng không
có ai ý ông à khi mà yên xuất thế này
sao lấy được ai đi để mà cho đấy á
nếu thể nếu làm thế được thì ổn in xuất
một phát mà lấy được cái đi luôn thì ổn
đỡ phải dùng xe xmax này cho Tránh
trường hợp bị nhầm nữa được cái đấy được
nếu mà làm được như thế
a Lazio thấy đồ ăn hay giữ làm được trò
đấy à
về con không gì ông Tống hết toàn bộ cái
này vào trong một trang sân nghĩa là chỉ
là cái cái truy vấn Insert là selec sẽ
xảy ra ngày ngày sau nhau để tránh việc
là có thằng khác can thiệp vào lúc mà
mình đang sẽ lách thì tự nhiên hoặc rất
vào nó sẽ Anh xin lỗi không ạ Các bạn
tống hết vào trong một trang xuân Có ai
có khả có một vài cách là như thế
Ừ ok
tiếp theo đó là hôm trước và mình dùng
recovery nhưng mà dùng dạng cdn Nếu mà
bạn nào chưa biết trả lại với ông nha gg
này à
Ừ thế nào là CD nào thì đây hôm trước là
mình có để đường link như này và mấy ông
thấy là đây là người đến hẳn của trang
web khác để mà lấy được thốt ra Switch
nói kiểu như này đúng ạ thì cái này gọi
là cdn chắc là sao tôi được ra tôi vẫn
chưa đọc đầy đủ tất là khái niệm của Cn
nhá Tối tôi nhớ mang máng thôi nhá Thử
nó lại xem không biết đúng hay sai nữa
Nhưng theo như tôi nhớ nó là
3cl nó là thứ nhất là đương nhiên là
Linh đến một cái trang web khác thứ 2
xong web phải lên nó là một con server
nó còn server khác và server thường nó
giống như trong các bình thường nó là
kiểu nó sẽ on 24 để mà ông hoàn toàn hẹn
nhúng nó về
bài hát Mất tiền lắm alo alo alo em bé
quá anh alo
thì cái á thì cái
Ừ cái cái này thứ nhất nó on 2T tư này
để mà để mấy ông có thể
luôn luôn truy cập được cái cái thư viện
đấy Vậy thứ nhất thứ hai là cái con
Server này đôi khi đôi khi nhé Nó là
được cung cấp bởi dịch vụ mạng theo kiểu
là nó ở khá nhiều khá nhiều quốc gia
thậm chí
ví dụ là ông nhìn như thế này nhưng thực
ra nó thể Linh đến tận mấy con server và
quốc gia khác nhau giờ sửa có ở Châu Á
có một con ở Châu Mỹ có một con hơn đại
hạn đại khái như thế
Ừ để để mà nó giống kiểu thằng Google ấy
để mà khi mà ông
sau khi khi mà ông gọi đến cái thằng này
nó sẽ tìm con server gần nhất gần nhất
để mà
lấy lấy cái cái này về nên về các bạn
thì nó lại khá là nhanh nó khóa nhanh và
đôi khi đôi khi nhá Tôi nhờ chính ra đó
là tới khi mà ông trẻ như này còn nhanh
hơn việc của ông ông cho luôn cả cái thư
viện này ở trên con server của chính ông
Ừ ông loát ở trên trình server của ông
Tại sao
anh Bởi vì khi mà người dùng vào mùa
trong máy vào đó thì khi mà có một cái
đường có mấy cái kiểu Swift chèn thêm
hay không phải mở Script mà Style hay gì
gì đó cho thêm thì người dùng phải loạt
cái đấy từ chính con server đấy Về mà
con server gái của ông là sự server
Ừ đấy của ông Đạt ở tít tận Mỹ Xa Xôi em
ạ Đấy xong rồi
Ừ thì người dùng phải tải tất cả những
cái đấy cái cái trình duyệt người dùng
hai tay rất là đúng lấy về từ bên Mỹ về
thì nếu mà giả sử mà cái con cdn à Ông
đúng theo toa cbn mà còn con server CN
đấy nó lại ở gần Việt Nam hơn thì nó sẽ
được lót nhanh hơn thì thôi
Ừ thế này là đấy tác dụng của Cn nhất
này Nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ hỗ trợ các bạn đôi
khi là nó sẽ mát nhanh sự thứ và Thường
thường mấy thì nó vẫn có thể truy cập 24
tư nhưng mà đã từng có lần kìa hành
chính thằng seri này Thế nhà cung cấp nó
bị sập hội lần đấy Chẳng ngại thì toàn
bộ trang web làm à mà đang đang dùng CD
nào để cái thằng Ri mà chết nóng lạnh
đấy đấy chứ và nhược điểm để nhược điểm
có nghĩa là duy nhất của cái việc là
những CN này
chỉ mình cách lên máy người dùng
1000 cái vụ à
bình thường là trình duyệt nó vẫn hỗ trợ
mình cách mà khi mà mình nhúng file các
bạn Nếu không ạ mình từng nói vụ mình
phải cày cả tiện ích nghĩa cách này vì
thường khi các bạn nhúng file ngoài vào
thì trình duyệt đôi khi nó sẽ tự động
cho các bạn một đấy hoặc gà mình có thể
mình cũng có thể cốt để nó nó cậu ép nó
kiểu nhớ mấy cái này đúng mình cái này
mình nên cách lại gửi thường ạ Cái đương
nhiên là cái file này về cơ bản thì nó
là mi rồi nó vẫn nhẹ Nhưng mà thường là
mình chả mơi Thay đổi cái này nữa anh ra
là mình cách lại được thì càng tốt không
ạ Ừ nếu mà mình lên kiểu tối ưu lại
khiến cho trang web lót nhanh hơn và
mình cách được cái gì thì cách không ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ
ok Bây giờ thì mình sẽ đến bài bài hôm
nay bài hôm nay thì sẽ là nhất là mua đồ
các bạn tra cái từ ra luôn mua đồ
à
Hôm nay tôi phải trả lại mua đồ WeChat
này
mua đồ dự báo là sẽ kiểu như khi bấm vào
thì sẽ hiển thị là một cái cái này thời
cao cái à
Ừ từ khóa của nó là có bắt cóc áp để
hiển thị ra một cái ngõ pat nếu mà các
bạn cha được ra nó sẽ hiển thị ra một
cái kiểu giống như Plus một cái Hiển thị
một cái thông báo nhưng mà trông còn xấu
hơn mua đồ nó một dặm pháp Nhưng mà
trong nó đẹp hơn Nó kiểu như hai đây ở
đây nói rõ Này bác Windows này lại đúng
không chồng nó đẹp hơn
đề thi
anh không không có thể tha tôi bảo mẹ em
không được dùng búa chát Nhưng mà nếu mà
tôi không muốn cốc chai các bạn mua đồ
nên hai nha tôi sẽ
bây giờ tôi sẽ cho phép mấy ông dùng bút
chat nhưng mà chỉ được dùng mua đồ thôi
không khó không được dùng à
3000 dùng không dùng Wechat cho tất cả
trang web dieu tra cho mua đồ thì được
thế hả Costa đẹp hơn tôi không biết mấy
ông như nào như cốt tay sẽ của tôi sẽ tệ
thì tôi sẽ
dậy luôn làm thế ở đây à
ở cái chỗ ở đây mấy ông thấy à Nó đã
chèn thêm với cả gì Ghi Wechat cho con
bú chat này nữa cái bút chat là gì thì
nó là kiểu phê thuốc không phải thư viện
nó Facebook xét để mà cốt sẽ nhanh hơn
tối ưu hơn nhẹ và kiểu
cho phù hợp với nói chung và mọi thiết
bị ngon đẹp và còn có bút pháp rét nữa
bootstrap cũng có gì hết để mà kiểu đây
xả sự cho mua đồ bộ ngày nay ngày thứ
anh
nói chung và bây giờ mình sẽ trên hết ba
cái này về mở đâu mà chính mình mình
đang muốn mình đang muốn làm như này nhá
đó là à
từ khi tôi vào cái trang này trở lại
Ừ thì về tài năng suất này bây giờ xử
tôi vẫn đăng nhập thì tôi thay vì kiểu
nhảy sang cái trang đăng nghiệp kiểu như
này như mình thì xấu thứ hai là
tôi tôi muốn thị ra một cái
một cái mua đồ đây bấm vào đăng nhập như
thì em mua đồ đây để đỡ phải phải đi dạy
lại cho em 10 cứ ấn đăng nhập này xử lý
âm nhập thì hãy nhớ rằng file khác song
điều hướng điều hướng đúng không ạ Tôi
không muốn như thế thì nó nhập vào nhìn
thấy một cửa sổ đây để tôi điền thông
tin đăng nhập vào nó nghiệp xong thì nó
cũng không điều hướng gì cả nó sẽ nó sẽ
đóng với mua đồ đi vào đăng nhập hộ tôi
đã hiểu thế bản trước là sẽ gọi Iraq lên
là đăng nhập hộ cho mình này sau đó đi
đổi lại cái ở đây là xin chào bạn a b c
đối ngoại này có thể tha thứ
Ừ nhưng mà trước khi làm ăn Nhật Nhưng
mình phải làm đăng ký trước không ạ đăng
ký đây mình sẽ còn kết hợp với cả và đến
để kiểm tra việc mình đã Điền đúng hay
sai gọi và tiền thì bây giờ xử đối bấm
vào đăng ký thì cũng phải thì em cái mô
rồi em ạ không ạ
Ừ thì bây giờ đầu tiên à
Đang ăn thì này mình sẽ tạm bỏ thẻ đi
mình không không còn thấy a nữa
thì
mình sẽ bớt Tân làm nút là nút là nó
đăng ký không ạ
Mình sẽ là
Vì mình thấy ai đi được mà bữa tuần à Xa
Ai hát này
ở lại bấm mà hiểu là đăng ký không ạ
à à
A và đừng như là cái file này của tôi là
phidex nhá đúng ạ Tôi sẽ viết vào trong
file index
chứ
không phải biết là trong phải mày ngu
rồi nhé Không Không Đừng có viết và file
nhé á
số tiền tôi chèn đoạn kia đã ngon Nó
truyền Ba cái đã
cho thịt gà tre này thì như bạn trước
nói thích thì chè ở trên cùng cũng được
chàng trai cùng nha được không sao cả
a thường em như tội nói thịt link CS thì
sẽ nên chèn thiên cung toàn bộ ra kết
màn ở dưới
nếu mà với các bạn được chứ cái đấy nó
liên quan việc làm ở
khi họ không ảnh hưởng lắm việc loát Vì
kiểu chị sẽ được loa thôi nhưng mà
nói chung là tùy gửi ra Kích thường tôi
tôi ngỡ nó được khuyến cáo nên để ở dưới
nhưng mà để trên này thời gian nó vẫn
đút lót tạm thời tôi cứ tổng minh trên
đi
ở
đầu tiên mình sẽ có đăng ký bấm vào thì
đây sẽ có đoạn Script vào đây xử lý là
khi mà nút đấy được Bờm không ạ
có
size up này click này
sau
khi nuốt được Bấm thì có điều gì sẽ xảy
ra không ạ kia ông bà em Số điện em ạ
Đấy
Có thể đây bạn bắn chết ở đây thì
thì nó sẽ cậu nó sẽ chích cờ nó sẽ nó sẽ
cậu nó sẽ thấy nghiệm hotgirl tưởng
chuẩn bị thơm từ này như nào nói chung
và nó sẽ gọi để thăm mua đồ Có ai có ai
đi
đây có một cái đít quá đi mua đồ như này
và sẽ nhìn chị ra đây cái đít như thế
này
tin tức là sao bây giờ Bây giờ nha
Anh An ơi thế không cần phải đặt như này
nữa quên lại không không không cần đặt
ngay mình sẽ chỉ cần à Có cái nút
à hay là nút này
anh vào Thaco đấy là được ok ok
em sửa lại tượng này tí
anh sẽ gọi đến kém mua đồ của mình là
mua đồ
xay ép
thế này này là được
3 cách lát này cho nút nó đẹp hơn thôi
bỏ đi cũng được
ở trong Sẽ Thôi nha này khi bấm mà thì
nó sẽ kiểu gọi đến cái mua đồ này cái
mua đồ này thì
thì mình sẽ lấy ở đâu Mình sẽ
nhà mình có thể chèn thêm cái mình sẽ in
Plus luôn cái file đăng ký này
a file Đăng Chí đây
a ch play đúng không có phải đăng ký đây
trẻ thiên thẳng vào tôi sẽ là
sau khi khi mà đào khi không đăng nhập
thì kiểu gì cũng chạy có mà mặc thì đây
sẽ là
hình ảnh Plus này
ừ ừ
có size
A
h.py
vào trong cái file jsp này
thì mình tặng xóa bên mình không cần
HTML nữa vì bây giờ nó sẽ bản chất nó sẽ
biến anh cái đít thì nó sẽ đít bà
em có ai đi là
mua đồ shop
sẽ copy đoạn này ở trong ai như này
à à
ở nhà mình sẽ phải chèn thêm một vài cái
ở đây để mà ẩn lúc đầu sẽ ẩn cái đít mày
đi còn nếu mà không ăn đi thì ông sẽ bị
hiển thị ra như này nó sẽ bị hiển thị ra
nghe này
Ừ ừ như thế bỏ luôn cả thí sinh start ở
đây đi
từ lúc đầu tôi sẽ ẩn cái mô bản chất cái
mua đồ ấy hồi trước tôi bị nhầm đó là ám
chỉ là khi ông chè khi người mua đồ vào
nó giống như là lúc đầu xong cái ông
ngay đúng không Ông nghĩ rằng mà khi bấm
vào nó mới được lót cái htl đấy lên
không HTML được loạt trước rồi chẳng qua
khi bấm vào thì nó mới được dislike nó
mấy chị gia Thôi cái này ra lúc đầu ông
phải có thêm vài cái flash là lúc đầu để
ẩn nó đi Đấy nó sẽ như thế này ông sẽ
chèn thêm cái class cho nó lúc đầu để ẩn
ở đi sau đó khi mà bấm bấm nút vào để mở
cửa kích hoạt đến với ai thì nó mới được
hiển thị ra đấy nó thế
em ấm hệ tôi nghĩa ở chèn thêm tất cả
đoạn này cho nó chuẩn của nó đi à
ừ ừ
à à
anh nhớ cái tự động sắp xếp của tôi bay
xử đâu ấy
ừ ừ
I wouldn't massage gohnson huyền huyền à
Lê Văn Tuấn Hiền của tôi đang bị nhảy
sang cái khác rồi
Ừ để tôi sửa lại nhé ca Angela
Anh cipriani
bí quyết định để mà sắp xếp lại mình cái
hẹn em à
em có nó sẽ cậu dám một đều
à à
à à em có các bạn hãy nó ăn đi khi bấm
mà đó hiển thị ra đó trông trông được
giao diện nó vẫn xấu thôi nhưng kệ thôi
nhé tôi tôi không dậy mấy ông dùng bút
tre đấy Ở ôm giao diện về hoàn toàn dậy
tôi chỉ cho mấy ông dùng Wechat đây với
ông là mua đồ trông thấy hoàn toàn bấm
vào nó bị ra nick là chỗ khác mà ấn
Escape đâu Hình như phải cấu hình nghĩa
vụ excape có thể dùng cái cái kia cốt
hay các từ thứ để mà tắt cái cái này
trên màn cái cũng được đấy
Ừ ừ cả notify ấy nhỉ Ừ thích cái tí tôi
ôm mà nó thấy file về cho mấy ông cũng
được
ở đại khái như thế mày không phải bấm mà
cho nó sẽ chỉ ra ông điền thông tin
nhưng mà khi mà điền thông tin ở đây mày
Ông thấy à bản chất nó vẫn là chân nó sẽ
nhảy đến cái máy này để xử lý đúng không
ạ Không Bây giờ mình sẽ lại cắn Hiệp Cái
này bằng Rocket tiếp mình sẽ dùng là
really kết hợp eject để mà đẩy cái pho
Mày lên hộ hộ mình thì đây nó sẽ có cách
đẩy như này tối thể biết ngay ra Swift
ngay dưới thằng này cũng được
à à
ở đây sẽ là vẫn là ra đi rồi ông ạ
ở đó là kệ khi mình điện khi mình
anh ở đây nhá Ở đây Đợi tí nhé
anh ở đây mình thường cái đặt ai đi theo
cái form này
Ông Bà mình sẽ chặn cho cái pho mày con
được dám ít Mình ở trạm cho mày không
được sớm ít khi mà có rất ít thì không
ờ ờ khi mà kia bấm sắm ít thì không dám
sát Mí
A và mình sẽ đẩy form lên bằng lá rách
đấy nó sẽ như thế mình sẽ là là sự ai đi
Ở đây Ford là
format size áp không ạ ạ
ở
đây à sau khi mà phẩm Sharp submit này
à à
chỉ riêng lần này tôi sẽ để lại đi vẩn
Tại sao lần này tôi sẽ không cho Ivan
được kích hoạt thì mình sẽ event
defoe là không cho nó được chạy như mặc
định sẽ ra được kích hoạt
Ừ nếu mấy ông làm à Không hiểu cái này
lắm thì mới không thể chơi trò là
ông để ai đi cái bước chân này và khi
cái nút là được Bấm thì cái for mà nó
lấy thông tin của Ford này
Ừ nhưng mà không cho con sẵn ít được
thay Thay của mỗi tuần mà sẽ là có tên
như thế này sợ ID của Tân size chẳng hạn
ở
u
xơ mít pháp chẳng hạn sau khi cái nút
này được bấm thì mình lấy thông tin từ
form hay vì kéo ngăn cho Phong không cho
sắp mi kiểu nghe đấy Nếu người chơi hai
cách
anh em đại phá là khi mà để on shop nick
có nghỉ thì như ghi nha Rồi được rồi là
hiểu nó sẽ biết đấy à
ở đây để tôi chạy thử xem có chạy được
nha rồi lâu chứ làm cái này bấm vào này
đó mấy ông thấy không Sắp ít đúng không
ạ
à à
Ừ
nếu mà không có vị vani fo thì nó sẽ sắp
ít được form thì thôi
không sao không hai bức tượng 200min
được Phen này ông nhầm rồi anh này nhé
ừ ừ
Có ai còn đến mà
nếu mà không có thai 3 tuần thì mặc định
thay nó sẽ ra sao mít này
từ đó thấy được lót cha nó ngon đấy
cho
nên là đây là một trong hai cách mà
không có thể áp dụng theo cách kiểu tôi
tôi sẽ dạy mày ông thêm cả
event iPhone nữa Nói chung là đại khái
là ok bây giờ ngăn không cho con chạy
nhưng mà mình cần lấy thông tin từ form
này để mà đẩy lên cái để lên để mà về mà
kiểu đăng đăng ký để không ạ thì mình sẽ
là Isaac
Vì sao đói tiếp và gọi đền cái file mà
file ghost shop
ở tp
lần này thay của mình sẽ là mình sẽ cần
à đẩy lên Dạ posts
các dữ liệu trả về dữ liệu trở về mình
thở da tím mình sẽ trả về là đúng hay
sai và mình có thể là trà về dạng kiểu
10 nếu như tôi từng nói một là thành
công không có thất bại thì tôi thể trả
về dạng HTML
HTML hoa dạng
bản chất trả về HTML thường hay là dạng
text trong những chính xác đúng hơn là
mình thì trả về dạng kiểu chữ hay cái gì
đó Rồi mình kiểm tra chữ còn ấy nó trả
lời dặn mấy cái dạng kia kìa Thì ông
phải thay đổi cái cái dữ liệu trả về
theo kiểu cấu trúc của nó dạn dĩ hơn ít
hết đôi xmer vân vân Ừ thì tôi nghĩ cái
đơn giản hơn
Ừ tí thôi cũng sẽ có thể được cập reason
Chắc là để buổi sau buổi sáng nữa
à Bố mày dậy thế nhiều cái nước quá tiếp
theo là thông tin mình chuyển lên cái
này quan trọng này không tên mình chuyển
lên là thử cái là toàn bộ những cái Minh
Điền trong form này nếu mà Mấy ông muốn
làm thì cậu nông dân vùng giữa từng làm
kiểu nông dân sẽ ra kiểu như thế này
cũng sẽ điền đầy đủ toàn bộ thông tin
truyền lên thật sự đây à nêm nè mình sẽ
lại
Đôla gọn đến thằng có đây thì ID cơ thì
tôi ở đây tôi còn làm phải chụp kiểu thủ
công này
nên bằng
phần mềm như này tôi làm chỉ là lấy được
Đúng ghi Nút này Của đúng kiểu nghe luôn
anh
thay vì như này thì bản chất là mình cần
lấy toàn bộ những cái điền trong phom
thì có sẽ có cách ngắn gọn hơn nó sẽ là
đô la ông thầy gọi dùng đo rít cũng được
ngắm chỉ là bởi vì trong trường này đua
giết chính người pho mà nó không ạ chấm
no life như thế Pharma like
để tôi tra lại nhớ là có mồ
like thì vui à à
Ừ để lấy toàn bộ những cái điền trong
phòng
à à
Ừ tôi chắn tôi không nhớ được cái từ
khóa lắm
I
read from
data cũng được
à à sealife Sunlight sôi thêm cả Ag nữa
để mà biến nó thành Mạc
em không nhớ được Thì trao Google thôi
Mày không ạ
thế này à
à à
các hạt vi quét ở như thế nào
ạ bây giờ sự tôi tôi bảo rồi tôi không
đẩy nó và Phone này à
Thế nên là tôi sẽ để hết nó vào trong
thành công nhưng mà tí mình sẽ xử lý nó
sẽ chia làm 2 trường hợp không ạ
à à
ạ bây giờ Giả sử nhé Vợ ăn inspect lên
này để với ông xem qua thôi à
bí ẩn ở bên Network này ấn vào bên ai
kia rồi Nãy giờ tôi đăng ký cứ Điền mấy
cái gì đó như này đăng ký để không thấy
là nó sẽ được đẩy lên bằng giấc rồi sau
đó thì ấn vào trong này kéo sang này nó
lớp vải lót thì mới Ông thấy hoàn toàn
là mình mình điện gì trong này nó sẽ
được đẩy lên đồ ngoại Đấy đấy là tác
dụng của cái Sunlight này nó sẽ lấy toàn
bộ những cái có trong form số mến theo
đúng cái nên của nó để nói chuyện lên
ông ạ
Ừ
cái nó đứng yên à bây giờ của bên mình
bên mình xử lý là mình luôn chả mình
đang không in ra một cái gì cả bố xét
Giáp ở đây mình không in là cái gì cả
ông ngoại mình đang có hết đồ nữa à mai
ngày hôm hôm đấy mình tắt hết đầu đây
rồi Ở còn có vụ mail đấy à
à à
ở nơi này mình thấy nó lỗi đúng ạ
đó là sự đây mình sẽ Thế chỗ ở đây
ở nơi này đi Bạn ship đóng này Đợi mình
tí nhé
Ừ nếu mà thành trùng email
Ừ ok
em bỏ qua vụ Huy mail hôm trước này à
có một vẫn phải tạo sẽ dừng em vẫn là
đạo lý dân như bình thường thôi một số
đóng thế cho ở đây là 18 trở thành công
nhận lại còn Đây Rồi mình kiểm tra nếu
mà trả về không phải là một thất bại ông
ạ
anh em cho điền đầy đủ tất cả thông tin
đi như này đăng ký lần nữa đây chúng
email rồi bạn chắc chứ đúng không ạ
Nhưng bên mình cần lại hiển thị thông
báo ở đây đông ạ Chị thông báo đâu đó
Khi mà kiểu mình mình sẽ có cơ chế Cường
nha là sự là mình sẽ đây sẽ có một cái á
đi xóa lại được
mình có mua đồ content
cho mình nhớ có mua đồ header đó là mua
đồ à
A header màu đỏ body
đây sẽ mua đồ body của tôi này cho bỏ đi
này a và có một modal-header Nã
ở
đây sẽ là à
à à
ở tiền đây sẽ đăng ký thi không ạ
a copyright iPhone đăng ký này và mình
sẽ có một cái á thường Hằng bút pháp này
nó có một cái để mấy lỗi đấy
đã lỡ dùng bút trái với tôi sẽ ôm nốt
cái cho mấy ông xem nó đi in ra cho lỗi
nó sẽ có cái đít này
mình thì lúc đầu tạm được trống đi nhưng
sẽ có ID là đít Euro này
và khi mà giờ sự là ít Bphone khác
ở
một mình dễ là
Ừ cái đít Euro này sẽ chấm a tách cũng
được truyền nội dung restore nào trong
này đây tôi cho tải lại trang cho mấy
ông xem
Anh đang sắp đi
nhờ đăng kí này điên à
Ừ cái này xấu xí à Ờ
Em đứng chờ
tôi không Nhớ lắm
Anh ngồi đây chờ
à à
từ lúc đầu mấy ông mới ăn cái đi không
cần phải hiển thị ra Nó kiểu như thế này
à
bí mật khẩu ngay đăng ký
xe tải chung email rồi bạn chắc chứ ông
ạ Anh thì chỉ là đây
từ lúc đầu nếu có thể ẩn này đi nhé mày
ông Nếu mà dùng bút chat thì ra mày
không biết rồi có mấy cái kiểu nó là
Style Display lần ăn gì vậy ạ
em không nhớ lắm
a
speedy spray
em phải trả hằn ở đây là được mà Style
này
Display là
năm tất cả lúc đó ẩn đi này
từ lúc đầu nó sẽ ẩn đi
ở nơi này Nhưng mà khi mà có lỗi thì
mình sẽ hiển thị nó ra thì mình lấy dùng
hàm trâu thôi nó sẽ hiển thị ra
Em bấm vào này
ở địa lại nhé á
ở đó như này ok chưa bây giờ sử nếu đăng
ký thành công thì sao đăng ký thành công
thì thì mình lại phải ẩn cái à
Lại thứ nhất là đầu tiên mình phải hai
ẩn cái alo đi ông ạ
Ừ thứ hai là mình sẽ kiểu
Ô thế cái Hà nó có khi không cần mình
chỉ đơn giản là mình cần mình đóng lại
cái này và mình đăng nhập thôi ông ạ
Mình đóng nó mình đóng cái mua đồ lại
cái cái cái đó mua đồ được ra là đây
em đang tra giờ buôn lại mua đồ ta chỉ
mua đồ đi rồi phải mô đồ
à à
thì mình sẽ khái niệm Total hot girl
không biết phát âm từ đấy nha đại khái
đóng được cái mua đồ đấy thì mình sẽ là
đây
có đền ID Model là
đi mua đồ
size.to girl này là được
Em hãy Tôi rất thích hà Mày hả mày Nó sẽ
luôn kiệm nó sẽ là kiểu còn dùng công
tắc đèn nó tắt Bật tất bật đi đón chị
hai chế độ thôi các bạn đang các bạn gọi
hàm này khi nó nó tắt thì nó sẽ bật lên
Còn khi mà nó đang bận các bạn gọi hàm
này nó sẽ tắt đi thế thôi Em chỉ nó sẽ
như thế này
Em bấm vào này điện toàn bộ thông tin
này thật sự là này sẽ trả lại email hợp
lệ này đúng loại đăng ký này
anh đợi mình đi
Ừ cái này nó trả về là chuỗi Chắc thế
những thành ra ba nó bằng là không được
Ừ ok
tại ra nhé
Em hãy đăng nhập rồi
à à
nhờ đăng kí này
Ừ tao girl của tôi nhưng mà có vẻ là
Ô tô xong rồi còn vẫn còn cái này
Ừ để rửa xe mà à
khi mua daso
Model tốt g Ok Ok môtô cơ nội tôi nói
tôi
à à
nhờ đăng kí này
điên này ạ
anh ấy
thế này không ra gì luôn
các
video sex ra đây à
Ừ đúng rồi nhỉ
Ê hồi gọi hẳn hay đi
à à
Ừ để xem nhé
đi mua đồ shop
Ừ thế thì bởi vì cha mình những bút
giống giấy không chạy thẳng đấy lại được
mà
A Gọi hài cũng được xe mà ai đi rồi
Không đúng à
Ừ đúng rồi Mua đồ sát
có sao đâu nhỉ
ăn sáng Đà
ăn rau xanh cả rồi à
à à
ở một số nơi đau não về vụ này tôi cơ
Này WeChat này
từ 0,2 nó không đúng đâu bởi vì à hay
nói chị ẩn ý thôi Còn cái nền cái nền
màu đen nó vẫn còn
đi chợ mua đồ đến nó là Phong chân tường
bị chứng tỏ là phải không gọi đến này
cô gái gọi đến một không tồn tại
Em nói sao
à à
có hai cái à Hai con bootstrap của mình
dùng bút khác của mấy ông kia nhé mấy
ông kia t bố cha mình đang cày mưa chap
Anh chấp ba
mua đồ Wechat à
ờ ờ
Logo xe máy
Em nói như bình thường nhé
ở show 2
đi mua đồ
gì tôi đang thấy hơi lại ở đây đây à
Ừ có gì đó Sai sai ở đây còn solo chấm
lót ra Cả ngày xem giá đấy thằng bộ đội
không
à à
anh khó ra
xe ôtô Audi tại vị chỉ được không mà
anh lại phải không nhớ à
à à
Em cứ thử nhé
anh không được không nữa
đi mua đồ shop
à à
ừ ừ
gì là khó hiểu à
Ừ bắt cô
sau 2
ở
bến xe máy
à à
hãy click mua đồ
anh đi tắt Hạ Long ngoài nữa nhầm
Anh bình thường mỗi khi tôi chạy cái này
vẫn được ngoài bằng cách thân tháng ở đó
là không chạy được
ở đôla đây sẽ trả nó khai báo giờ này vì
vậy thay ra đi rồi
anh trai gọi đến rồi ra được rồi
à à
khi
bạn mua đồ nhà ai
à à
Ba Mẹ tao cơ sở được rồi Vừa nãy không
được
à à
số
tiền Bỏ ra cho vừa đi nhé Chị gọi cho
tôi nhé
à à
Xe tải tự nhiên đừng Cái này nền này nữa
Nghe ca nhạc
em
hẹn cho anh chơi thủ thuật kiểu ngay
à à
Ừ thế hệ xong à
ở đó
chơi được thử thật nhiều ngay à
A Gọi mua đồ
A Gọi Tower không mua đồ vừa rồi không
báo báo nó không tìm thấy cái Hàn mua đồ
không đi ở xa đỡ là chèn thêm với thư
viện Hàng ngày về thì đáng lẽ phải chạy
được mua đồ thấy lạ
Anh tốt ra lại dùng được
Anh không dùng để hàng gọi lên các ham
mua đồ đấy ok
Ừ Ừ kệ chứ nó vẫn thế là về này nó vẫn
đúng rồi mà ok bây giờ tiếp theo là mình
muốn thực thực ra là thế này thiếu lòng
tin đó là mình cần lấy khi mình Điền
xong mà cho mọi thứ ổn này rồi mình cần
lấy thứ nhất là
Nếu như các bạn thấy là bây giờ mình
phải tải lại trang thì nó mới
xe tải lại tra thì nó mới thì xin chào
xong rồi nút đăng xuất đúng không ạ thì
vừa mình không muốn như thế Mình đóng
với Mua đồ xong thì mình cần hiển thị ra
được cái chao thì bạn thân ở đây mình sẽ
phải sửa lại cái đoạn đấy Đó là
ở đây thì ra là cái phần à
em tôi đặt cho nó một cái gọi là phải ai
đi à Một cái class
anh ở đây Bây giờ mình cần mình cần làm
nhé đó là mình cần à
thay cái cái Menu này
anh có hai cách mấy ông nha Một là mấy
ông nha
mấy ông có thể tạo đâm cái Menu không
không phải làm thì cậu dạng kiểu như thế
này nữa theo kiểu lại ít em thì ông hiển
thị ra mà ông ông làm theo kiểu là cho
nó dislike là là năm đấy Cái ẩn tạm bạn
ở đi sau đó ấy khi mà thành công cái này
thì ông this Player sau để hiển thị nó
ra thì ở sẽ ổn hơn để từ từ thử làm cho
mấy cũng dễ hình dung nhé
các em à
hai
tay nói đi ừ
Ừ nhưng mà có như này
Ừ nếu mà không có thì mình sẽ là
i300 bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
cách đăng xuất lại chào xem show hành đ
ý nghĩa là khi mạng
à à
em mới gọi này vẫn phải sai sai là
các em à
Ừ nếu mà không có đúng không ạ
Ừ
anh nếu có chứ nếu mà có thì mình sẽ là
a Display là năm này à
thế này à
à à
ừ ừ
em bỏ Arina
ở đoạn này mình không Thế thì da trông
có vẻ phức tạp hơn phức tạp hơn này ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà thường là người lạ không chơi
cách này về sao tôi không Dạ email phải
em giúp em này đâu có gì đang hướng dẫn
ông là có thể làm được cái trò kiểu ngay
thôi
à à
nhà mình có chèn file này mình chuyển
file được làm chè động được như thế mình
cứ chen file ở đâu được đi để nó dưới
này đi theo thì sẽ ra
I search in Club des sciences chẳng ạ
Con eo cái kiểu ngay Nếu mà không đăng
nhập điện thì có thể hình nút 2 file này
I play style cho nó lại tiếp tục là nếu
mà
gà trống thì ẩn này đi này
ăn này đi này à
ạ Bây giờ ông không có ship từ cái này
nó kêu chị sẽ lỗi nhưng mà ông Ẩn đi nó
sẽ không bị ra nữa làm cách 2 mà dễ hiểu
nhé Ae
Ừ anh đang sau nha
à à
anh hả
a shyne shyne cũng có vụ
em xin start võ sĩ study đ
trà xanh yên tĩnh sau nhé tạm bỏ inplus
ai nỡ loạn đã
ở đây Nói chung nhà khi mà ở mấy ông
đăng nhập và thì mới ông sẽ đây Đấy cái
Menu của tôi nó vẫn còn nhé
cho em địa chỉ a menu của tôi nè
I know this place chẳng ngoan ăn nữa Dạo
này nó lại lỗi tí
xin chào đây lỗi vì À bởi vì rõ ràng đây
không có tên của người người đào cả
nhưng tạm không có tâm
tự hào Ok bỏ
lỡ thì Rốt cuộc gọi Isaac chẳng có tác
dung dịch à à
ờ ờ
anh cứ cứ để chào nhé không ta Mẹ không
hiển thị lỗi người dùng cũng là một cách
còn bé ông muốn chặt chẽ hơn để em kiểm
tra đấy hỏi cháu mà dâm nữa cho Dũng
ngay là được cái Sao nó không lỗi
Nghe nhạc xem hiện đúng rồi nó sẽ không
lỗi
Ừ cái này kiểm tra này có tồn tại thì ấy
nó ra không thì
À mà bạn này làm tiếp để làm tiếp là
khi mình ăn nó đi này và mình cần hiển
thị ra gái
U22 hai cái này hay Cái này mình sẽ à
mình đặt tên nó flash cũng được
a-class là
menu à
Ừ nó tin là Ngạn và khi đăng nhập được
anh sai đi
lo in his khi đăng nhập vào Sign fake
size
khi đăng nhập vào thì cái máy nuôi được
hiển thị ra đấy như thế này
ừ ừ
Á Châu Anh bị ra cái nút này nhưng ngoài
ra là mình sẽ cần phải ạ Điền cho cái
này mình có stein này có anh một cái
span ở đây
anh ta mình có ai đi nó là spam lên ạ
Để mình mình Điền Tây nó nó mà nó không
ạ à
add
ID slame này chấm tách này
sẽ bằng cái gì thì ra bằng chứng kiến
lên mà mình đã điên thế này này thì các
bạn có thể lấy nó là
đô la
input tại nêm đấy à
em lên mạng lên đấy
Cái cái ngoặc vuông này Nói chung là cái
cách selector con này là của xe hồi nãy
mình nó quay chấm ba lô lấy giá trị nữa
anh
chậm khá lằng nhằng thường à Tôi đang
dậy rồi mấy ông ấy chồng mình biết qua
thôi mình thường ít ông chứ em dụng kiểu
nó kiểu này lắm
nhờ đăng kí này đi ăn đây ạ
à à
khi nhìn ai có sợ chung nha nhiều lần
tôi gõ gửi xong mà vẫn bị trùng các bạn
đăng ký nhé đó ngon rồi đấy nếu mà mình
cần à ẩn hay ngay đi này thì mình cần
lại cho thằng ngày hai cái class là
a menu à
Ừ ừ
hôm nay Lucy gà không Cái này phải đặt
tên nó như thế nào ấy để Manu guest là
người đã người chưa chưa có tài khoản đi
vào đây menu Rơi là người có tài khoản
cái để rõ phân biệt nhà cũng được
mà menu
goetze sẽ ẩn đi này
thử lại phát nữa
ở đầu tiên ngay đúng không ạ Điên à
Ừ
ông leakless máy in U2 ạ
đó chưa chậm phải dưới chữ nghiệp như
kiểu dạng kiểu
nhưng rồi Mỗi tội loại cốc này ông thấy
cài nó càng dài đó nhược điểm Gia Huy sử
ca về sau các bạn Thể cốt một cái file
HTM
tôi hồi ấy Tôi bị nghiện really mày
không ạ kiểu xong rồi ngồi mò mấy cái
này so với cùng thời ra một cái file
HTML đôi cũng 100 vòng thôi nhưng Duy
rồi lên ba bốn năm ròng thì nó Kế file
rất dày và thực ra nó về sau rất phức
tạp bằng nhạc Nếu thấy gan nhìn loại này
trọng rất lằng nhằng không tối ưu thế là
thường bây giờ chắc ai làm dùng kiểu
nông dân kiểu ngay nữa mà sẽ dùng Trung
Quốc nghĩa là bấm vào cái này chỉ kịch
cái kia nó sẽ tự động thay đổi ra tiện
trứng vậy Ở kiểu mình phải gọi tướng
hành tinh tăng thì ẩn hiển thị Nga như
này nó khá sợ không ạ
khi nhìn lại rất sợ đấy về sau không có
một đống đít xong Còn đống ai đi rồi
class
làm nhá
Ừ nhưng mà em vừa ra mẹ nó qua việc làm
mới nghỉ thì em mua cái mua đồ không ạ
để mà để mà đăng ký mạng xong rồi các
thứ thứ
Ừ chắc đăng nhập thì méo làm tương tự
nhé Bỏ qua Bộ đăng nhập Đi tương tự thôi
I
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ dạy nốt các bạn về bên
virus nhỉ
xe tải lên nhé
ừ thì bấm đăng ký nó sẽ có một cái váy
đấy Ở đây mình không đi ăn gì đó ấn ở
đây sẽ chị lỗi bên cạnh gì đó Sao nào sẽ
như thế nào ạ
Vì sao không thấy cười đi
Ô
kìa mod thì mình sẽ dùng cái YouTube rồi
vides thừa tôi gọi về đi tơ Bởi vì nó có
thư viện
khá nhiều thư viện thôi đấy tôi dùng là
bút chép về đi tơ
Em chưa biết là bây giờ nó còn cứ điện
không hay gì gì đó Download
Ừ để mô tôi hãy xem demo là xem trong
ngày nhé bấm vào này bắt buộc phải điền
này hay không đẹp
Vì vậy tôi nhớ có phải thằng này hơn
em bấm rồi này
Ừ bắt buộc phải điện
gà trống sĩ mà đúng không gõ đấy hiển
thị được thành công đại chạy trong những
xin phép chị cách ngon này không biết là
có kết hợp cả rồi rách không
tôi xem nhé
à à
chị xem trong bài liệu nó xem có kết hợp
với gạch
Ừ bắt buộc phải điện này
Ừ anh và đi tơ này for eset sau đi chơi
ừ ừ
Em email
à à
khi tôi đọc nãy giờ nhờ không có relax
đúng
à à
em không Có Biết vậy hồi tôi dùng đã
có thể dùng cần cream by fender strat cơ
em hãy nói kiểu kiểu như thế này
Ừ rồi
chị xem nhé
khi sex
ừ ừ
vì nó có khi để Mesut kiểu hãy Tôi rất
thích cái để mới ship đấy và đến này
à à
ừ ừ
ở
đời cô smile pallet này
ừ à nó choáng mì thớt Ok Ok cái này để
mà thêm được ZicZac Tôi tôi muốn chỉ mấy
ông có có thể một cái thư viện được cho
là ổn không phải thư viện mà chỉ có đầy
đủ những hàng mà mếu muốn mà giờ xử
giống như tôi và bà có thể thêm chèn
thêm những cái kiểu điều kiện khác của
mấy ông thì phải có một thư viện nó mở
một tí thôi dậy mấy ông ấy thư viện mò
sẽ ổn hơn hay có cái vụ đấy đã ngon thôi
Ok để đau Lát nữa thôi
khi download hoặc dùng CN
ở đây
ở CNC
à à
ừ ừ
cách chèn thêm
chanchan thêm sữa này phải chèn dưới Duy
nhé
ở thời sự dùng cái mini II ừ ừ
Anh muốn chèn thêm rửa Gia Huy nhé mày
không nghe à
a hlc ạ
à à
dự báo thế Thế là mấy ông xài được rồi
ạ bây giờ thử đọc tài liệu luôn anh tài
liệu nó được ra
có thể thao đơn giản gọi đến Hàn này là
Xong
cái nhớ hả mày thì kiểm tra tương đối
à mình mình mình cần mình còn phải cấu
hình cả cấu hình cả Mỹ ship cái thứ tư
nữa
Em thấy có hướng dẫn ở đây này Tiếng
Việt là nói như thế này rồi mà ông tiện
vãi chưởng nữa
ở mình người đi sau đầy đầy cái có hết
rồi không ạ
A
gọi đến copy đoạn này ra sau máy cuộc
sống chơi nạn đến thế à
ở đây Nói chung à bây giờ thì không phải
sắp mít nhé này nữa
à mà virut có thử Thư đã
à à
Em có nhớ là khi nó nó có cả khi mà
thành công ấy thì thành công thì mới
mới sắp ít đấy
à à
các video sớm nhất Sony
Ừ cái này đã chạm sắp ít rồi nhớ cái này
nó trạm xăng ít rồi
anh không biết hai này cùng dùng được
không Không phải có một cái file một cái
à
Em sắp mít handle này
à à
Ừ
thôi Chả biết cái cái
cốt World Cup này có dùng đúng thư viện
của tôi không cơ thư viện tôi tại về
không cơ
i a Do nó ok ok
sau khi mà
khi format for some ít này à
à à
em nici phòng không cần sắp Mít đã mình
sẽ
đứt đoạn này vào đây
à à
cho
mấy thì gọi đến phòng đấy vào đây sẽ ra
form này
khi họ
ở bên này sẽ ra
sản phẩm site này à à
khi chọn này vào đây và giết con Focus a
gì đó không ăn trọng ra mấy cái đầu mày
xuống trọng bỏ đi chậm lại rồi này luôn
này rồi sẽ theo nêm nêm của mấy ông nhé
nêm này bắt buộc điên đấy độ dài lớn
nhất là gì đấy email này
nếu không thể phải đây nữa không thể
thêm những cái Du nào
ở đây sẽ ra
ừ ừ
ở Aqua tu lại Hà Ru nó là email vậy
em ngồi viết khó hiểu đây
Em
email và chu Chắc thế thử
à à
a password will be equal password này
đây phải điền lại password tôi còn chẳng
có điên lại bắt Quốc thật sự có đi lại
bất World thì hai cái nó phải bằng nhau
này khá được đúng loại này là sự điện số
điện thoại hai cái thứ thứ
ở nhà mày ra đây tôi tạm không phải đấy
đi tôi thẳng về để tương đối đi là sự
thế là mình sẽ tôi Tôi muốn in ra cảm ấy
suýt nữa là khi mà thai có vấn đề không
ạ
Hay chạy lỗi thì mình sẽ in ra lỗi như
là mình sẽ có in lỗi cậu bắt buộc phải
nhập tên đúng không ạ
Đây cậu ngay Rất tiện được
à à
AE nhập email sai rồi nã
chuyển ngay
ừ ừ
gì
đấy
Mày không sẽ thấy ở nhà Nó rất tiện này
à
Còn nếu mà không đi mình có nhớ là nó
dùng cái mặc định của nó không tiếng Anh
thì phải à
à à
Ừ để tôi chạy thử cho mấy ông xem nhé
áo sơ mi Note II
Ừ từ xem Tại sao lại sắp ít luôn à
khi có khi không gọi được cái hàm này có
khi không gọi được hả mà
Chị xem thử nhé
ở
đây đến nào là phong chiến đấu ngoài cho
sẵn rồi không gọi được hàng này cho
firmino của mình a size của mình có thể
ở
chị xem phim CG gồm
có nó rồi chìa khóa à
Ơ sao lại nhé
Nha Trang
I can't find nữa thử có thể file đi à
à à
ừ ừ
em bị lỗi
các em ạ
I
really lại ở đây dưới này tiếp này
em thấy do tôi nghĩa là phải đẩy Thằng
này nó xuống cuối Ừ
tối thứ Bảy nó xuống quá nhé á
à à
Ừ địt
vì nó không thấy tác dụng nó chưa đầy
xuống cuối nó mới nhận bởi vì gỡ ra là
là
Ê thằng Midu gọi trước à phải được lót
đã xong rồi thoại mới lót để nó chèn
thêm bạn Nếu thấy tao không
Em hãy ấn vào đây Okay thấy chưa
Ừ thế được rồi không ạ thì đi ăn xong
đầy đủ thì mình sẽ sắp it for thôi
lại như này à
khi đăng ký
khi
đăng ký xong nó sắp ít luôn ạ Mình sẽ
form event ở đây phải ngăn phóng Mít
ờ ờ
em hẹn đồ đây
sản phẩm prevent the Force
chị xem nhé
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
Ừ có gì Các isp này xem
à à
Xin chào mừng trong thằng ngày nó cố Tôi
không quen cốt thằng này lắm
Có thằng này cứ kiểu gì
Hôm
nay tôi thử Ford
chấm prevent the force Em à
nếu tôi không nghĩ chẳng làm được form
trong trường hợp này nó hơi sai sai rồi
ý là có thể thốt ra ship của tôi có thể
chết được đoạn dưới này khiến cho nó lỗi
khiến cho nó không bắt được cũng thể
Em thử nhé
có solo chấm lót 1
chị sẽ tự do I
ừ ừ
à à
thì hơi khó chịu đấy à
ở
chỗ giảng có đoạn này
a móc tắc vãi chưởng
à à
ở ngoài chuyện vài thư viện thông đấy
a huy.com nữa
à à
Ừ chán thế này để ngăn việc phóng trăm
nghìn à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
khi mở mà dụng Ajax form này mình mình
từng dùng cái Asphalt này
I know For máy Thực ra nó lại kiểu ác
Lấy thông tin từ iPhone thôi
à à
cách chèn hôi nhiều sự kiện hàng ngày Nó
kiểu nó kiểu gì ý
à à chị
xem nha
em nấu sắp cuối
anh không được thì tôi sẽ làm mới của
nông dân
à à
em vừa rồi nói đi lỗi vừa rồi nó bị lỗi
rồi Sắp mít luôn
Ừ ok
xe
máy méo để kia rồi Giỡn nói đĩa lỗi
ở
nhà em hay là nó không nó không chặn
được cái phone
Ừ tôi thể để đây à
đặc biệt đội đây hơn ít không biết được
không
à à
em không có không được
a
cho thẳng luôn Sao mày không được sẵn ít
luôn đi à
à à
ừ ừ
Ô Long 1
Ừ mình mới ở trại
em vừa rồi năng có lỗi gì nhỉ Chắc là để
phom developer ở đây không được
này nông dân ở chưa
Ok Bây giờ mình phải kết hợp cả hai cái
cùng lúc đó Hà Nội tại này
à à
Ơ
cái thằng phom phom này nó là cái gì nhỉ
nhỉ nhỉ
cho tôi trong thường ngày Tôi không chắc
để đôla giết ở đâu nên tôi phải gõ lại
đầy đủ như này à
từ
đó đưa rồi
Em thử sắt cái này đi xa nốt ruồi ở
ừ ừ
khi đoạt được đặc không cần lời ve này
nữa OK tưởng phải thêm các từ ve nữa thì
UCWeb Ok Sao vừa nãy do là lỗi cốt ở
trong này khiến cho Kiều cái hàng này
không sẽ được nên không nó không ăn được
việc là vì vendor for for mà sắp Mỹ luôn
Ừ ok
100 cách đơn nhiên à mình mình kiểu gì
cốt sẽ có bức Nhưng mà quan trọng là
cách mình giải quyết được mình cho các
bạn hình dung được cách xử lý do cái
Facebook như thế nào tiện nhanh không ạ
i7 thế Sao nghe coi như bạn thấy là hôm
nay mình kết hợp với cả
dùng mua đồ này dùng cá thứ khá nhiều
nhà ngon thế hôm trước à hôm sau trong
làm thêm cả những chị thông báo được
Nói chung là cho các bạn với qua thôi
thì các bạn còn thắc mắc hỏi gì không ạ
xe
máy xong cái này rồi này
A và bếp xong rồi này à Chú Chó Thông
báo đầu tiên find a
anh
sữa bắp Nhanh nhá
tại khái vừa lỗi ở cốt này thôi Nói
chung lỗi đâu đấy nhưng mà ông kiểu
comment tắm đóng lại đúng ạ xem nó chạy
Xong rồi
Tại một con sâu lót ở đây xem ạ là còn
chạy đến hàng có source Lấy không Nếu mà
có những rò thôi đến đoạn đấy nó vẫn
đúng Còn nếu không thì ông Ngoại có số
ra ở chỗ khác không ạ Cứ thấy chữa rằng
thôi
à à
tự học tiếng công nghiệp tin cần giỏi
tiếng Anh không
vừa rồi mấy ông thấy tôi lên phải lên
đọc tài liệu nào Nhưng mấy ông thấy tôi
có người đọc tài liệu nó
tôi chỉ cần biết một vài từ khóa Thôi để
mô xong rồi Isaac đã dùng sắp ít cá thứ
đúng không ạ
nhưng mà tôi có đọc tí gì nó viết gì
không Tôi chẳng đặt gì cả ông ngoại tôi
chỉ có cốt Về Thôi đọc code hiểm
ừ ừ
à à
ê
kê Nói chung à Bố mày chán chỉ tương đồi
Yên Thế thôi nhỉ
Ừ có gì các bạn thắc mắc thì hãy nhắn
tin hỏi Dương hoặc là bình luận sau nhé
Bạn trả bạn nhé
ừ ừ